tap the Oracle grid and some stuff out
of storage from everything firm projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath I was
partners with Hank on a project called
Goliath how big did you get by record 21
feet you 65 feet 65 hey everybody is
Charlie this is gonna be my a man in the
wasp Easter eggs hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie obviously
spoiler warning if you have not if
you're finding me for the first time -
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway that I'll explain at
the end of the video a lot of great
laughs in the film probably one of the
literal biggest Easter eggs is Cassie
Lang as stature most of you probably
detected how they were trying to
foreshadow her becoming stature
eventually she's practicing being a
superhero with Scott when they're
playing in that box for it at the
beginning of the movie then at the end
of the movie hope turns to her and
straight up ask you know what do you
want to be when you grow up but she says
I want to be a hero and help people like
my dad just making your ears prick up a
little bit because recently Kevin Feige
said oh yeah we're definitely laying the
seeds for a Young Avengers movie
Cassie Lang stature character was a
member of that team so everybody lay in
your Avengers for conspiracy theories
about flash-forwards because supposedly
a 16 year old version of Cassie is going
to appear during Avengers 4 she might be
the stature character when we see her
again but the funny thing too is that
when they're having that conversation at
the end of the movie and they're
watching the movie on the iPhone that's
actually a moment directly out of the
comments where Scott actually goes to
visit his daughter who's at school they
watch a movie together
on the iPhone by shrinking down but the
actual movie that they're watching is
them exclamation point
it's an old b-movie about giant ants
when Goliath opens up the tin and the
giant ants pop out he says it's them
exclamation point there's just another
reference to the movie that they were
watching on the iPhone at the end of the
movie Baba Yaga
got one of the biggest laughs in my
theater but that's an actual character
that's appeared during Marvel's Captain
Britain series so it actually is a real
thing the ghost character also a big
corporate saboteur character from Marvel
Comics very different origin story from
this version of the ghost but because
it's a relatively minor character I
totally didn't mine sunny birch is also
something of an Iron Man villain who's
crossed paths with him in the past
even the corrupt FBI agent that was
working for Sonny Burch in the movie was
a comic book character named Geoffrey
Ballard who's also popped up during
black goliaths comic book if you're not
to be comic book reader the Goliath
comic book character got his own solo
title for a little while it was called
black Goliath no surprise Randall Parks
character was hilarious maybe someday
he'll figure out close-up magic but he's
playing a comic-book character his name
is James woo his first appearance was
yellow claw number one as you would
assume he's just a Coulson type
character that pops up and reacts a
really crazy stuff that's going on
Laurence Fishburne of course playing the
Goliath character we didn't get to see
him but they do talk about their
adventures together he's a beaut doing
Avengers number 32 within the MCU though
Goliath was a part of shield like he
says he grew to 25 feet tall he was just
an alternate version of giant man who
worked with the Avengers when Hank Pym
was doing other stuff in the comics so
the other Easter Egg here too is that
they do a Laurence Fishburne flashback
like they D age everybody during the
movie when they do flashbacks but
instead of using the face swapping
technology that they use for Michael
Douglas and Michelle Pfeiffer they just
had Laurence Fishburne's son do his
scenes so when he goes to find the
ghosts 30-plus years ago and says I
think we can help you please come with
us that's actually Laurence Fishburne's
son they did the same thing during the
Black Panther movie where you have the
old version of takaka and present-day
the actors real-life son played the
younger version of takaka when they did
the 90s flashback to Oakland whole bunch
of Microverse quantum realm Easter eggs
some of these are pretty deep cuts so
when Scott gets kidnapped by Hope early
in the movie he's watching Animal House
on the TV but the scene that he's
watching is of Donald Sutherland
character getting super high and talking
about there are galaxies within atoms so
it's literally them referencing what is
the quantum realm of the MCU within the
Animal House movie so obviously you
probably know about Marvel's legal
problems with using the term Microverse
what happens is is the reason why it's
called the quantum realm and not the
Microverse because there's a race of
beings called the micronauts that live
down there is because Marvel didn't
actually call it the Microverse in the
comics until they did a comic
book that was based on a toy line they
don't own the toy line so when they lost
the rights to that they also Lots the
rights to using the micronauts name and
the Microverse where they came from but
let it be known that when Janet Van Dyne
is trying to explain sort of the
mysteries of the quantum realm in a
couple short sentences
she says she survived there because the
laws of physics are different time moves
differently
she's been changed she's evolved
fundamentally there are other beings
besides those giant tardigrades that
live down there we probably won't meet
them until ant-man the wasp 3 hopefully
those continue to explore this new
universe that's down here in the quantum
realm it really is like a whole other
universe of stuff that they could
explore in however many movies they want
to speaking of universe obviously we're
still dealing with the blowback from
infinity war you probably detected the
snap shirt very poor timing on their
part for that post credit sequence
because they were all turned to ash but
Janet Van Dyne did reference that ghost
was existing in multiple realities
simultaneously because of her quantum
state instability but also there are
time vortices within the quantum realm
you could get lost
accidentally time travel on a whim so
now ant-man is one of the most powerful
Marvel characters maybe not the most
powerful but he just has access to
things that the other characters don't
so he just became vastly more important
to saving the universe in Avengers 4
Stan Lee's cameo was hilarious it was
pretty easy to spot it was just during
the car chase when they flew by his car
and he thought that he was having a
hallucination because he apparently did
too many drugs during the 60s well the
60s were fun but now I'm paying for it
even though I totally understood the
budweiser what's up I actually hadn't
seen that commercial in a long time but
that was a real commercial if you
watched a lot of TV during the 90s you
probably remember it
there was a really sly Laurence
Fishburne matrix reference when they
interrupt him during his lecture at the
University he actually is trying to talk
about alternate realities but then just
scribbles the word matrix on the board
before he runs out with them I did a
video a couple days ago about it because
it was also a Captain Marvel Easter Egg
but during Iron Man 2
Iron Man also references project Goliath
and some stuff out of storage everything
from project
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath I talked
about it briefly earlier this week too
but ghosts father in the MCU
is actually egghead from the comics he
was a classic Hank Pym Janet Van Dyne
ant-man and the wasp villain but he also
put together a number of evil teams and
was also a member of the Masters of evil
so like they say that he was trying to
create this technology the quantum
tunnel for another group that was either
Hydra or like we say Sonny birch was
working for other people that wouldn't
take no for an answer I did a video
about that too because it's like this
whole big open-ended thing that they
could turn into another big plot point
in another Marvel movie there were a lot
of people that said that they could see
fan OHS at the end of the movie when the
finger snap went down while Scott was
collecting the quantum energy all these
colors exploded when he was collecting
it that looked like the colors of the
Infinity Gauntlet but supposedly people
are saying that they can see a cloud
outline of Thanos his head in the
background just like someone working on
the visual effects sort of layered him
in in a really subtle way so if there
were any other Easter eggs that you guys
spotted that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments I know we have all kinds of
theories about how now because of these
twists Scott is going to help out in
Avengers 4 so I've got plenty more
Avengers 4 videos that will be posting
soon we'll get that Captain Marvel
trailer and Comic Con is next week I'll
explain what's going on with my schedule
next week in the next couple of days
they're finalizing all the panels so
I'll talk about all the trailers that
are gonna drop but there is a new round
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner when I post
new Marvel click here for my post
credits scene video and click here to
learn all about Nick Fury popping up
during spider-man far from home thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you